إن فعالية هذا النوع من
العلاج محل خلاف كبير وفي
تركيا لا يزال على الهامش ولكن
الأطباء مثل علي تيم كل منهم
يجربون النحل ليس فقط
لعلاج التصلب الجانبي الضموري ولكن أيضًا التصلب المتعدد
والتهاب المفاصل الذي يذهب التفكير عند كل
لدغة تغرق الجسم بها  المواد الكيميائية
التي تقاوم الالتهاب أفضل من
الستيرويدات التي يصنعها الإنسان
بالإضافة إلى أن
معظم الناس لا يبتسمون
ويتعرضون للسع من النحل ، فقط ما
نحتاجه نعلم أنه حتى أو يمكن أن يلعب دورًا في
عملية مكافحة الالتهاب ، لذلك بعد
هذا العلاج يكون أقوى مثل
جراح أعصاب لا أصدق حقًا أن
لسعات النحل بغض النظر عن عدد الأشخاص الذين يمكنهم حقًا
مساعدة شخص مصاب بمرض التصلب الجانبي الضموري جيدًا ، فأنت متأكد من أنك تعرف
كيفية جعل الأشياء جيدة ولكن
ليس هناك شك في أنه قد تم إعطاؤه لمن سيحصل على
حبوب منع الحمل بمفرده لا يأمل
متجذرة في التقاليد القديمة ،
رأى شانا سامًا ومورقًا ، بالتأكيد
بدأت في غسل السيارة ، لذلك
لأنني تعثرت في مكان أعلى تذهب من
محبوب